This summer, we're getting honest about summer blockbusters past and present.
This is honest trailers. Blockbuster summer.
This episode is sponsored by Google play with the help of seven deadly sins,
grand cross
In the early two thousands adults with change the animation game,
but only one classic animated series made fans sit up,
rubbed their eyes and say, Oh, I missed off watching hunger boards again. Ah,
fine. I'll watch whatever this is.
[Inaudible].
Oh crap. I think I like anime now.
Cowboy bebop experience a Nawar filtered future
where humanity has spread into the solar system and covered it in hot,
steamy jazz,
where there's so much crime bounty hunting is part of the gig economy that
attracts only the heaviest Chainsmokers.
It looks like a plain old moon rock to me now.
Hey, how much is it worth? If we try to sell it.
There are basically Uber drivers with a few more guns,
strap it with a crew of the bebop,
a group of misfits each with their own mysterious and complex backstories that
you're not going to get much of. Okay.
I remember everything, really everything except my own life.
There. Spike Spiegel of me lean fighting machine.
Who.
Also has a literal, mainly
Fave Valentine. Who's perpetually broke. If I get rid of my body,
I won't need money. Perpetually levy.
Yeah,
I have to go.
And perpetually wedgied ed, a genius hacker who talks like Elmo.
Edward is Edward. Ed has never seen this before.
Ed knows where it is today.
It goes looking for this Ruki mysterious alien.
I am a super intelligent corgi who mostly just acts like a moderately
intelligent corgi and jet that guy,
your mom dated for a while after the divorce.
Complaining and be thankful there's something to eat.
Then don't come back. There won't be a place for you. Good Britons.
You're not my real dad together.
They'll team up to take on the vicious crime boss known as vicious
occasionally, but mostly they'll be focused on food.
It is hungry. We haven't had anything to eat in two days.
I haven't eaten Brimore halibut in a long while we just came here because
there's good food. I am starving.
That's all there is making a quick long.
2.5 Million 6,300,
5,350.
Or just kind of hanging out.
But no matter the adventure,
you can bet that the thing that gets mentioned at the beginning of the episode
will be super important. I want to be a tough.
Guy. Like you, you know, come on, I can do.
It. And super depressing.
Master. You see it? I was fluid like water. Yeah.
Don't try to talk anymore. Hang on. Now don't die. Don't die.
Wow. That is that enough to conjure up some introspective Sachs music.
[Inaudible].
Anyone else hear that?
Or is that just when my brain sounds like when I watched the show?
So revisit the all-time classic anime,
that was probably your gateway drug into the hard stuff that clearly, uh,
inspired other shows about scifi Outlaws turned family in a junk between your
guitar strings,
that mixed Asian and Western aesthetics that was followed by a movie with mixed
reviews. And while they both might have some all-time great things. Arms only.
Cowboys is a literal Bob
starring bed had redemption Alita, bounty angel,
jet blue, ed, ed, and envy dog.
The bounty Hunter fee with vendetta illegally brawn.
Lady,
lady.
It's better. If you leave for today, there are other bounty heads to catch.
You don't need this one. If you see spike again,
tell him that I'll keep waiting.
Celebrity cameos. What com Tonka guy,
spirit Abdul Hakeem. I'm Whitney haggis, Knutsen, Moto your lawyer.
I'm the youngest chef rubbish.
Because I'm here with my own twin sister. Now days,
a three eight pneumatic tube. Isn't in style anymore.
Moto Crow, Cowboys.
That's where I met a cowboy. You know what they say?
Cowboy cowboy. You're a cowboy.
Are we taking this cowboy thing a little too far and actual cowboy?
See you space cowboy
American healthcare coming up with 13 million war logs for the basic.
In addition to the 54 years of interest payments, 300 million,
28,000 per lungs, Twitter,
people who believe instantly in dramatic fantasies can be controlled.
By tiny dots of light and 2020 Northern good country on
the earth anymore. Wait, lounger.
Oh great.
They're making a live action adaptation of my life story who stuck with that
job? Oh, nice. See a space cowboy, uh,
make that see you after you recover from knee surgery space cowboy,
it doesn't quite have the same ring to it.
Episode is sponsored by Google play, get seven deadly sins, grand cross,
and discover more on Google play. Now.
Whatever happens happens, Vivity bop to the beat of cowboy bebop spot.
No idea what that means and you will shed tears of Scarlet. Wow.
Okay. That's gross.